hey guys welcome back to another video
it's a very late Thursday night so I
don't know if this is gonna be up
Thursday night or Friday morning either
way I do apologize for being a little
bit late or very early for you guys I
just it's just within the timing me
either way there's a few things I wanted
to talk about really quick
first off the gameplay is probably gonna
be [ __ ] I really don't deserve my gold 3
ranking I did play in the tournament
I did receive gold 3 I really don't
deserve it but do that as you will in
the beginning of the video is going to
be the community the community's opinion
so far on the tournament and then the
later part is gonna be my opinion so you
can hold off the weird angry comments
and the dislikes for all that stuff for
the quick either way I'll just get
started so there are three things people
were talking about or hate about the
tournament and it's bugs and glitches
rewards and the player slash community
so we're gonna start with the bugs so
the first post was from reddit and it
was a guy's experience talking about
ranked mode for the first time and it
says I get into two matches lose them
both sadly my game crashes after the
second match and I get back into for
honor it puts me back into the
tournament and it keeps me at this one
screen so I decide to abandon because
I'm stuck there and it gives me a
one-hour penalty and then another post
saying honestly I don't know what
Ubisoft are thinking of releasing the
game in this current state basically
they're saying the foreigners a bit too
glitchy for them to be releasing a
ranked mode and with the character
balances above which we'll touch on
later it really shouldn't have been
released and I do kind of agree on that
to a certain degree they did talk about
a few bugs that were causing the ranked
mode to not work properly and they said
that we're going to fix them but there
is a couple other things that are
working on that's why there is this big
thread on the reddit page with a threat
of patches that are that they need to
know about something and patch them
immediately so if you do have any of
these send it to them I am already
sending these to them as well
even if they have an even if these
people have already done it already just
to get the awareness for it and then the
next one which is a definite one that
needs to be sent to them is the video
provided by Electrolux on reddit so
thank you for that and just want you
guys to watch this real quick
your team has been eliminated from the
quarterfinals what so yeah basically if
you missed it he executed the
Peacekeeper she raged quit and he still
got a loss for it this is another one of
the bugs that needs to be fixed cuz who
knows maybe that guy could have won the
tournament but the game denied him of it
anyway moving on we have the rewards and
this was majority of the posts on the
reddit and to show some of you some of
the people were angry that they spend
hours and hours trying to win a
tournament only to get an ornament for
the character they don't play so they
have to play the RNG game and hope they
earn a reward that they want other
people on these posts were suggesting
ideas like giving an ornament for the
character you're playing as in the
tournament but then what happens if you
play more than one character in the
tournament who knows they reverse and
talk about that maybe it's like if you
get whatever you play in the finals
matter if you could the semi-finals but
you have to make it there this is a
whole debacle about that but once again
just throwing some ideas around someone
also just suggested that the steal on XP
gain should be a little bit more in
tournament seeing as you wait forever
for the matches to start let me guys
know do you think about that let me know
if you have any ideas tell me in the
comments below I'd really love to know
moving on to the last topic though it's
gonna be the community and their
characters since it is a tournament and
people will be trying their hardest to
win there's no doubt that they'll be
playing the best character but oh my god
every match I have played today has been
Centurion peacekeeper warden or a Raider
except Lovering our face which you saw
in the gameplay but I haven't seen any
other character besides them and on top
of that players are either waiting for
you to attack and then turtle when you
do or cheese you with exploitable moves
like the Raider charge it makes high
level play an even average level
tournament play like a gold level not
enjoyable or fun anyway regarding the
rest of the stuff we talked about and my
opinions on them I wish the rewards were
better and not being given a pattern as
a reward in the semi-finals
also I do agree with the rewards only
for your character it would be nice but
then it comes into play if you played in
a more than one character Ubisoft should
probably have released this later when
the
Mehta changes were fine were finalized
as well as some of the bugs we talked
about previously like the one with the
Berserker player but I have to give them
credit though it dig it does give
players an incentive to play the game if
they don't have one so definitely points
for them either way that's gonna be the
end of the video guys sorry if once
again it's a bit late either way that's
gonna be the end if you did like the
video please sure to hit the like button
subscribe if you're new to more for
honor content my recent video is gonna
be up on screen for you we did a recap
for the dev streams you don't want to
miss that there's some bits of tidbits
of information coming either way that's
all I have for now guys and with that
see you later peace out